during this pandemic some major sporting
events
left las vegas maybe things are changing
now sports director chris matthews joins
us live in the studio with
an event that is actually coming to las
vegas chris
that's right christian yeah we've been
talking about some of these big events
leaving las vegas
it's great to see an event that is
actually debuting here in las vegas
this spring the lpga is coming back to
las vegas it's been years since the
ladies were
swinging here but today the tour
announcing they're teaming up with the
mgm to bring
the bank of hope match play event to
shadow creek this may
former champion and las vegas resident
daniel kang will be playing in this
event
along with many others from las vegas
here she played a little bit today for
us
the field will include 64 the best
female golfers
playing one of the most prestigious
courses in the country
and isn't it great to see something amid
this pandemic
launch in las vegas i've lived here long
enough to notice the difference
when i first moved here and when the
vegas golden knights started coming in
and this place is a community like vegas
las vegas is a home and everyone sticks
together and
for us to have a golf event here i know
that pga tour has a shriners tournament
but
we wanted some lpga tournament back here
is because
they pride on sporting events out here
and
it's not just a strip we have more than
that we have things around
that 1.3 mile of las vegas that is
entire community that would back you and
support you
now the event takes place the end of may
will feature match play so the field
will be whittled down to the final two
on sunday should be exciting golfers
will be swinging for a share of one
point million
in prize money they are hoping for fans
also by the end of may remember the last
time
we walked that course phil mickelson was
playing tiger woods
in a one-day winner-take-all made for
television event